bonsoir claude georges maison merci
d'être avec nous des démocrates qui son
blog bien au parti pour l'emporter une
courte majorité que signifie cette
potentielle victoire des deux sénateurs
démocrates bas en effet ça c'est assez
c'est une surprise en réalité puisque la
géorgie est un état traditionnellement
républicain c'est un état sudiste qui
fut autrefois ségrégationniste et qui
est en principe acquis aux républicains
il avait deux sénateurs républicains
mais il a donné une courte majorité à
joe biden à l'élection présidentielle
résultat que d'ailleurs tonale train peu
conteste mais qui a été certifié par
toutes les autorités de l'état de
géorgie qui sont d'ailleurs tout
républicaine donc il se trouve que les
candidats qui semblent devoir être élus
sont deux démocrates
l'un avec une majorité de 56 % ce qui le
mettrait à l'abri si elle est confirmée
d'un recomptage automatique l'autre
monsieur sauf avec une majorité
simplement de 50 2% ce qui pourrait
donner lieu à un recomptage automatique
puisque c'est en dessous de 0 5% par
rapport à aux 50%
donc on va voir le résultat définitif
mais il est très vraisemblable que tous
les deux vont être élus et en effet ça
veut dire que la sociologie la
démographie de l'état de géorgie a s'est
modifiée que il ya un rajeunissement de
la population que il ya une évolution
des idées que d'ailleurs attentat est
devenu le troisième centre de production
signol cinématographique les états unis
donc ce n'est plus le vieux sud
le vieux tubes du vieux sud agricole
c'est à un état dynamique et on voit
bien qu'il ya un équilibre maintenant
entre les uns et les autres entre les
républicains et les démocrates
et puis le fait que monsieur trump est
martelée depuis des semaines et des
semaines que cette élection avait été
truqué a peut être aussi conduit
certains républicains à rester chez eux
puisque l'élection est truqué pourquoi
voter alors que blanche maison il ya
aussi on en parlait il ya quelques
secondes les fameux certification des
résultats de la présidentielle qui ont
débuté il ya à peine une heure au
congrès grands moments de tension
puisqu'on le voit au moment où vous nous
parlez que le blanchemaison il y à ces
manifestations des supporters au trump
serait même se seraient même introduits
à l'intérieur du capitole le bâtiment et
serait désormais confiné selon la chaîne
nbc ses occupants se serait réfugié dans
les souterrains on peut s'attendre à une
grande journée longue de tensions aux
etats-unis c'était prévisible chez très
insolite c'est très solide qu'on soit
dans une configuration quasiment
insurrectionnel où les manifestants
prennent d'assaut ou votre tente de
prendre d'assaut le capitole et n'y
arriveront sans doute heureusement pas
mais encouragée par le président sortant
c'est une situation probablement sans
précédent en tout cas aux états unis
alors effectivement la constitution
prévoit que des sénateurs ou des membres
de la chambre des représentants peuvent
objecté aux résultats qui arrivent
certifié par chacun des états puisque
les états unis étant très décentralisé
fait chacun des états fédérés qui
certifie le résultat de l'élection est
en réalité cela certification avec les
deux chambres réunies convoquons en
congrès c'est en réalité une formalité
d'ailleurs le président là monsieur
nixon vice président à l'époque a
présidé un exercice de ce genre où il a
certifié parce qu'il n'avait pas le
choix
l'élection de son principal rival et est
arrivé la même chose monsieur al gore
qui a un certain nombre d'années plus
tard et par conséquent monsieur baydan
va suivre le même cours des choses et ne
s'opposera pas à la certification
il l'a dit publiquement il l'a répété
tout à l'heure mais de toute façon le
vice-président américain est évidemment
respecte la constitution et en plus il
est soucieux de son avenir politique on
dit parfois qu'il pourrait être candidat
à la prochaine élection
et naturellement il va suivre le cours
ces objections par un membre du sénat où
un membre de la chambre des
représentants conduisent à une
suspension de séance et chacune des
chambres se réunissent séparément pour
étudier l'objection qu'a fait un de ses
membres est bien un débat qui peut durer
jusqu'à deux heures suivi d'un vote
le résultat ne fait aucun doute mais
comme vous l'avez dit docteur ça va
durer probablement toute la journée
peut-être toute la nuit ça des vins
dépendre du nombre d'objections qui
seront soulevés pour le moment c'est un
représentant de l'arizona et un sénateur
de l'arizona qui ont soulevé par écrit
une objection qui normalement devrait
être en cours d'examen fini avait pas ce
confinement due à la situation de la
manifestation sur les marches du
capitole
une chose est sûre en tout cas tu te
penches maison c'est que pour le moment
à la séance a été interrompue après
réellement une irruption d certains
manifestation contre up dans le bâtiment
du capital à tel point d'ailleurs que le
maire de washington vient d'imposer la
11ème tomber un couvre-feu à partir de
18 heures dans la capitale américaine
sans doute des manifestants est chaude
et chauffé à bloc par le discours de
leur champion c'était à 17 heures heure
française donald trump qui a tout de
même affirmé qu'il ne conseillerait
jamais la défaite assez étonnant quand
même de la part d'un président de la
plus grande démocratie du monde comme il
se présente même
oui c'est très étonnant il a réaffirmé
sur tous les tons nous ne considérons
pas cette défaite on m'a volé ma
réélection
c'est ce qu'il a dit devant ces
manifestants à 6 heures de l'après midi
heure locale de washington donc c'est en
effet une situation de blocage assez
grave
que peut faire le président donald trump
pendant les deux semaines qui est lui
reste à exercer ses pouvoirs à la maison
blanche eh bien on en a un exemple ce
soir
il peut en effet provoquer des désordres
pour empêcher le cours normal d'une
transition menant à l'installation de
joe biden mais il va surtout lutter pour
garder le leadership son leadership sur
le parti républicain
le parti républicain qui est divisée
parce qu' un certain nombre de
responsables républicains
et puis les institutions qui les
soutiennent les chambres de commerce par
exemple se sont prononcés pour dire il
faut arrêter ça tout de suite parce que
nous avons besoin de garder nos chances
pour un candidat républicain dans quatre
ans et dans l'est aux élections de 2024
et par conséquent nous devons respecter
les institutions en plus pour des
raisons qui tiennent à l'ordre public au
fonctionnement de l'économie en période
de vide par dessus le marché
évidemment il n'est pas très opportun de
déclencher ce genre de contestation
radicale donc le prévienne trump est en
difficulté et il veut
garder le leadership sur le parti
républicain la situation est grave elle
peut mener d'ailleurs à une scission du
parti républicain qui serait issue
extrême que naturellement les
responsables de ce parti va essayer
d'éviter
et puis le président reste le chef des
armées et on a vu cette lettre
extraordinaire il y a quelques jours de
cinq précédents ministre de la défense
secrétaire à la défense aux états unis
qui quel que soit leur parti ont signé
une lettre pour dire qu'il fallait
surtout pas mais les larmes et l'armée
des états unis d'amérique à la solution
d'un problème politique qui était le
résultat d'une élection
l'armée n'avait rien à voir rien à faire
avec ça les institutions devaient
fonctionner normalement pour décider qui
était élu président des états unis est
effectivement 6,5
ancien milieu de la défense ont fait
cette lettre c'est probablement que le
problème se posait et on a su en effet
que dans certaines réunions à la maison
blanche le président des états unis à
poser les questions qui pouvaient
impliquer l'entrée en jeu de l'armée
soit en utilisant la loi martiale dans
certaines zones dans certains l'état
soit en décidant de frappes ponctuelles
dans certaines zones sensibles comme
l'iran sur des installations nucléaires
et bien entendu les chefs militaires et
lémance majorité de ses conseillers
landis fait d il reste deux semaines qui
sont deux semaines qui vont être
délicates qui vont être dangereuse parce
que donald trump ne renoncera pas et il
n'assistera probablement pas à la séance
du 20 janvier d'installation de son
successeur
peut-être sera-t-il ce jour là sur son
terrain de golf
merci beaucoup que le blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales